I think I need to lose a little weight
President Trump just announced tariffs
on fifty billion dollars of Chinese
goods and half the planet seems to be
screaming about a trade war neither the
administration nor its critics are right
because the tariffs will actually have
little impact the administration is
right that China coerces US companies
into transferring technology and steals
other intellectual property outright
they're also right that the WTO has
failed to prevent this and US action is
overdue but the 25 percent tariff on 50
billion dollars will only cut imports
from China by about 20 billion imports
from China rose twice that much in 2017
we won't even notice these tariffs for
that reason China doesn't have much
reason to act on its own to retaliate
they will certainly threaten to do so in
part to scare other countries from
copying the US but they need trade with
the US more than the US needs trade with
China so it's in China's interest for
this dispute to stay limited right now
this is a tempest in a teapot but
eventually people are going to notice
that very little has actually changed
and that eventually may coincide with
the start of the 2020 presidential
election campaign we're not done with us
yet what do you think about taking a
tougher stand on China let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI